como lo dices ya el debate se ha
trasladado a la cámara de los lores que
es el debate es el senado en este país
en este momento los lores están
debatiendo la viabilidad de esta ley por
supuesto será una aprobación sencilla
como en la cámara de los comunes pero
será un debate largo hay por lo menos
más de 100 lores inscritos para hablar
un debate que se prevé de 5 horas pero
sin mayores sorpresas seguramente será
aprobado rápidamente posteriormente una
vez la cámara de los lores y la de los
comunes han ratificado esta nueva ley
que tiene 80 páginas entonces la reina
isabel como jefa de estado será
consultada para que dé su consentimiento
firmará la ley y entonces se convertirá
en una realidad a partir del primero de
enero de 2021 en la cámara de los lores
hay que estar pendientes porque pueden
hacerse las modificaciones a este texto
bueno vamos entonces a ese momento
futuro luisa como iniciará la aplicación
el primero de enero
será el inicio de un nuevo capítulo
entre el reino unido y la unión europea-
una nueva relación de aliados históricos
el inicio de un acuerdo comercial que no
tendrá tarifas ni cuotas pero si
requisitos hay mucho que se transformará
pero también hay que ver sobre la marcha
que va cambiando se acaba por ejemplo y
es bien importante la libre circulación
de ciudadanos europeos el reino unido-
pondrá un nuevo sistema migratorio para
los ciudadanos europeos que quieran
venir a estudiar oa trabajar deben
demostrar suficiencia en inglés y tener
un nuevo tipo de puntos para poder
recibir el permiso de vivir en este país